c'est une question de nathan quelles
sont les preuves de l'existence de dieu
llosa cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode de ask la série nous c'est vous
qui posez la question et merci nathan
porta question je vous parlais de 5
preuve de l'existence de dieu c'est pas
le top 5
c'est luce 5 preuve que j'aime bien je
précise tout de suite quand je parle de
dieu je crois pas forcément d'un
monsieur barbu qui nous regardent qui
est omniscient avec qui on pourrait
rentrer en contact et c'est dieu ça peut
être aussi par exemple une substance
transcendante éternel infinie cause
d'elle même et clients tout un petit peu
comme genre la force dans star wars
bref du coup ne vous bloquez pas sur
cette image de dieu cette vidéo n'a rien
à vrai que les religions les prophètes
les dogmes etc
on va juste parler de l'existence de
dieu du concept de dieu et sous toutes
ses formes des cartes a annoncé
plusieurs preuves de l'existence de dieu
dans les méditations métaphysiques et
hélène que j'aime bien en fait il part
de l'idée d'un film alors on a tous eu
cette idée d'un fini en nous de manière
innée or on est fini ou même mais on est
fini autour de nous tout ce qui nous
entoure et fini sous qu'on expérimente
et finit donc comment ça se fait qu'on a
cette idée d'un fini en en fait des gars
tu expliques ça par une entité qui
aurait mis cette idée d'un fini nous et
qui elle-même du coup infinie coup à
cette entité c'est dieu le vrai mais cet
argument c'est qui dit qu'on valide et
d'infini
sauf que john locke par exemple n'est
absolument pas d'accord moi non plus je
la vis sur saint pierre pour ceux qui me
suivent
en gros c'est pas vraiment l'idée d'un
fini pour nous c'est l'idée d'une non
finis claque au vent négation de l'idée
de la finitude
c'est exactement pareil tu vois on
n'arrive pas à appréhender complètement
l'infini ça t'arrive pas penser vraiment
l'infini par contre tu le penses à ta
pensée quelque chose qui n'est pas fini
et ses différentes il ya une nuance
alors c'est pas une étourderie ou un
oubli de descartes lully pensais
vraiment qu'on compense l'infini et le
dit même dans son livre qui vous parle
pas du mont fini mais je parle vraiment
de l'infini à la manière où on en pense
le repos et pas seulement l'absence de
mouvement à la manière dont on pense
l'obscurité et pas seulement l'absence
de lumière etc
mais voilà pour pour l'infini en tout
cas je suis plutôt d'accord avec jack
blog c'est à dire qu'on pense ou non
fini est en fait l'idée de fini et une
idée simple quand je pars d'idées
simples mais une référence à l'hebdo /
john locke jouer mais dans la
description manier cette idée simple de
fini pour donner ce bon fini du coup vu
que tout le raisonnement repose sur le
fait qu'on ait l'idée d'un fini
bastarache alors ça c'est un argument
ontologique
il y en a pas qu'un allaitement auto
logique c'est un argument ou pour
prouver l'existence de dieu
on va prendre la définition de l'être de
dieu s'avance elle ni part du fait qu on
a l'idée de dieu dans la tête
jusque là pas de problème on a tous déjà
penser à dieu ensuite il dit que dieu
pourrait exister dans la réalité et pas
de contradiction intrinsèque à l'idée de
dieu qui plantait choix d'exister et
ensuite il nous explique qu'une idée
elle est forcément plus forte plus
grande plus importante si elle existe
aussi dans la vie réelle du coup si dieu
n'existe pas dans le monde réel
ça voudrait dire que son idée pour être
encore plus grande et plus forte
or c'est pas possible puisque c'est dieu
et que le dieu ne peut pas être plus
grand et plus fort
donc il ne peut pas exister seulement
dans son esprit et vu qu'il existe dans
ton esprit c'est à dire qu'il existe
dans ton esprit et dans le monde est là
aussi on pourrait revenir sur cette
preuve avec quand par exemple qui nous
dit que ba dieu existe tu existes c'est
une tautologie sa lettre c'est vrai dire
la même chose si je prends dieu comme
postulat t par son existence partis
constituant de ce qu'il est con comme un
exemple plus simple
l'exemple du triangle si on se pose en
triangle on va pas affirmé qu'il n'a pas
dans parce que quand on s'est posé un
triangle on a établi qu'il avait trois
angles quand saint-anselme dit que dieu
ne peut pas être plus fort et plus grand
ah ouais mais c'est la définition même
de dieu c'est un petit peu le serpent
qui se mord la queue
quoi
ça arrive qu'on te demande l'origine de
l'univers à quelqu'un il va dire ah bah
c'est comme ça l'univers il a toujours
été là voilà c'est un peu chaud
moi je me promène en forêt je trouve un
caillou par terre et que je dis d'où
vient ce caillou si quelqu'un me
répondent à tour et là je vous imagine
ce caillou tu le lagon dit adam dît
énormes et n'ont maintenant et c'est
l'univers à une question se pose est-ce
parce que l'univers est énorme et qu'on
met dedans quels punk aux points bien en
2003 le mathématicien board
elvis un but et les flammes qui nous
disent que n'importe quel univers en
expansion
visiblement le nôtre ne peut pas être
infinie au passé et donc à un début et
aussi le théorème de penrose cooking qui
va dans ce sens en mettant en évidence
un instant ce drone univers donc il ya
un début de l'univers est donc acquis
tout cela engendrait ce début et ce
quelque chose cette cause
elle est forcément dans une réalité qui
est au delà de l'univers qui est
transcendantale univers elle est au delà
de l'espace temps parce que l'origine de
l'univers
bref dans l'univers et donc on a une
cause qui est nécessaire qui peut pas ne
pas être qui engendre une entité
contingentes there qui pourrait ne pas
être cette entité c'est l'univers du
coup on se retrouve face à une cause
nécessaire qui peut créer l'univers ou
ne pas créer une livre en gros on parle
de quelque chose qui a la liberté de le
faire ou non on parle de quelque chose
qui peut créer l'univers par sa volonté
on parle de dieu le problème de cette
preuve et réside surtout dans cette idée
de début l'univers en fait parce que ces
postulats de base
il n'est pas prouvé aujourd'hui quand on
est moche un modèle pour unifier la
théorie de la relativité générale et la
physique quantique et qu'on n'applique
ce modèle à la description de l'univers
primordial c'est à dire l'univers ya
très très longtemps
et bien ce qui serait le point d'origine
de l'univers soit il s'évanouit
soit ils se déplacent dans le temps il
s'éloigne et à chaque fois donc
aujourd'hui on n'a pas la preuve
scientifique que l'univers a une origine
on n'a pas non plus la preuve il y en a
pas
la théorie des mondes possibles c'est
une théorie surtout philosophique qui
dit qu' il y aurait d'autres mondes avec
d'autres logiques que les nôtres alors
ça n'a rien à voir avec la théorie des
multivers en physique la théorie des
mondes possibles sadique par exemple il
ya un monde vient mon possible ou cette
figure et liste il ya un monde où les
licornes existe et donc il ya un monde
où dieu existe or si dieu existe dans un
monde où elles existent dans tous
puisque tu est un être infinie maximale
transcendant et donc s'ils existent dans
tous les mondes
eh bien elle est vice présidente cette
preuve entre vous moi le raisonnement je
reste sympa mais un peu pourri je les
mises dans l'eau parce que 500 grammes
chiffres cool mais si tu veux et par
quand même du principe qu'il ya là un
monde où il ya une licorne et superman
qui sont en train de se prendre une part
pour ceux qui veulent en savoir plus sur
les monts possible je te revoilà les
travaux de david lewis et voilà c'est un
petit peu aberrant quoi je trouve je
pense que même dieu il n'y croit pas
vous êtes tous déjà vu matrix l'idée
c'est qu'on est tous ensemble dans une
simulation informatique 60g que la
germaine ca trù vous êtes tout seul dans
une simulation informatique
tout autour de nous pourrait être simulé
et le conseil dans sa programmatique
gyan et aujourd'hui il ya rien n'a
aucune preuve qui permet de réfuter
cette théorie or ces théories est vrai
pas forcément dieu existe si l'on
voudrait dire que là quelque chose qui a
créé notre monde qui est transcendant et
que notre monde est régi par cette chose
c'est un peu la démission de dieu
c'est le succès qu'on peut pas prouver
aux réfugiés qu'on n'est pas dans une
situation mais sinon rien à dire
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu sur
la même thématique j'ai essayé de sortir
incessamment sous peu un coup de fil sur
le pari de pascal et j'essaie de sortir
un nouveau programme l'a fait à les neuf
mois que j'y réfléchisse a mûri
doucement et c'est là c'était quatre
mois que je me penche sur une identité
graphique sonore un nom surtout qui me
plaît je pense avoir trouvé là je
travaille je fais les finitions et où
donc voilà ça fait bientôt je fais une
vidéo pour vous présenter ce que c'est
il est possible que je mette aussi une
autre preuve ou un début de preuve en
tout cas je sais pas on va en discuter
ensemble sur facebook sur la page
facebook et suivez là aussi puisqu'il va
y avoir une annonce de live bientôt
n'hésitez pas à poser d'autres questions
sur facebook twitter ou les compteurs de
la vidéo il est possible que je fasse
une vidéo sur cinq preuve de la non
existence de dieu mais c'est pas sûr
supérieur tous à dépendre voilà parce
que j'espère qu'il n'a pu encore une
fois et ciao